wow
what i did ich kann nicht vergessen was
er getan hat er hat sich 170 menschen
getötet
der lose personen natürlich ist das
etwas an das ich sehr oft denken muss
ich kann also nicht sagen dass ich
jemals wieder ein normales leben haben
werde
aber ich
wünschte ich wäre damals im
regierungsgebäude oder auch wie teuer
gewesen so dass er mich aufgenommen
hätte
nein ich habe seit vielen jahren keinen
kontakt mehr zu ihm alles was ich über
ihn weiß habe ich aus den zeitungen
denke es ist absurd wenn er wird nicht
herauskommen wahrscheinlich die nächsten
20 jahre nicht ich will nicht dass er
raus kommt weitere tote
weltexklusiv konnte annika rage mit dem
vater von anders breivik sprechen ein
mann der wie wir eben gerade hören
konnten gebrochen ist gebrochen ist von
dem was sein sohn für gräueltaten taten
begangen hat annika rasches uns jetzt
auch zugeschaltet verfolgt live den
prozess wo dieser mann dieses monster
jetzt um seine freiheit kämpft annika
wie hast du den vater dieses monsters
erlebt
patricia du hast es gerade auf den punkt
gebracht gebrochen der vater von anders
breivik es ist tatsächlich gebrochen man
hat es gerade auch an seiner stimme
gehört überhaupt über seinen sohn zu
sprechen fällt ihm sehr sehr schwer
macht es auch sehr sehr selten wir haben
ihn gestern getroffen in einem ganz
kleinen beschaulichen vorort von oslo
erst dann vor seine tür getreten seines
kleinen holzhauses ist eine ganz
beschaulich gegend und bestanden mit ihm
dann im schnee und er hat uns dann eben
ein bisschen über seinen sohn erzählt
und man merkt dass sein sohn anders
breivik ihm das leben genommen hat ohne
ihn eigentlich getötet zu haben und er
hat es ja selbst auch im interview
gesagt ich wünschte dass er mich
genommen hätte stattdessen
also er kann immer noch nicht darüber
sprechen und auch erst recht nicht über
das gemeinsame leben ich hatte ihn dann
nämlich auch angesprochen auf breiviks
jugend und auf die gemeinsame zeit aber
da hat er dann abgebrochen und hat auch
gesagt dass er sich dazu nicht mehr
äußern will weil eben sein sohn immer
noch teil seines lebens ist dadurch dass
er immer wieder daran erinnert wird aber
er eben nicht mehr darüber sprechen
möchte jetzt gerade annika warnte
sprichst sehen wir in den gerichtssaal
betreten soll bis dort vor ort wir sehen
wie anders predigt dieser mann der 77
kindern das leben genommen hat jetzt
dort für seine freiheit kämpft und wir
sehen wie wir ihn auch beim prozess
bereits erlebt haben selbstbewusst
reinkommen wie wirkt dieser mann auf
dich
ich war relativ überrascht wie schmal
und wie gleichzeitig trainiert anders
breivik wieder war er hat wir hatten mit
dem psychologen der ihn damals
interviewte mit dem kriminalpsychologen
mit dem hatten wir in unserer doku
gesprochen von knapp einem halben jahr
mein kollege peter hell und ich und da
hatte uns dieser psychologe gesagt dass
breivik bei seiner tat genau 80 kilo
wiegen wollte er wollte nicht 79 kilo
wiegen er wollte nicht 81 kilo wiegen
aber wollte 80 kilo wiegen und auch
jetzt wird er wieder sehr durchtrainiert
dass es mir aufgefallen die stimmung im
saal hier wir sind hier gerade in einem
gericht in oslo in genau demselben
gericht in dem anders breivik vor zehn
jahren verurteilt wurde ein stockwerk
über mir und wir schauen uns das hier
aus einem presseraum an und vor ort ist
auch liesbeth rheinland sie ist die
sprecherin der opferhilfe und hat damals
selbst ihre tochter verloren wir hatten
sie auch damals in unserer doku
getroffen und wir müssen ich muss
wirklich sagen die stimmung gerade im
saal war sehr gefasst obwohl da
beteiligte überlebende als auch
angehörige saßen waren sie alle sehr
gefasst lisbeth räume land musste eben
als anders breivik dann anfing zu
sprechen musste sie glaube ich relativ
ungläubig schmunzeln klicken sie dann
auf ihre linke zu einer
anderen frau die neben ihr saß zum glück
hatte sie gerade runter gesehen als
anders breivik dann seinen rechten arm
hob genau und jetzt kämpft anders
breivik darum aus dem gericht aus dem
gefängnis entlassen zu werden die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist aber sehr gering
dass das passieren wird er morgen wird
auch eine psychologin sprechen die
anders breivik seit zehn jahren schon
betreut und selbst die hat gesagt dass
sie eigentlich kaum eine veränderung bei
anders breivik bisher gesehen hat aber
darüber würde ich gern noch kurz mit
jedem sprechen annika das ist ja
eigentlich eine völlig crew die idee
schon überhaupt dass man nach so einer
stadt für dieses ohnehin keine gerechte
strafe auf dieser welt gibt dass man da
noch auf die idee kommt vorzeitig aus
der haft entlassen zu werden das heißt
gibt es irgend eine mini chance
tatsächlich das dass dieser ja
schreckliche fall eintritt
nein die chance ist tatsächlich sehr
gering ich habe auch gestern noch mit
einem kriminalpsychologen gesprochen
paar grünendahl und er hat zu mir gesagt
dass es eigentlich ja das ist einfach
sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich ist das
anders breivik da rauskommt ich habe ihn
dann gefragt warum glaubt dieser mann
überhaupt frühzeitig entlassen werden zu
dürfen und da hat er gesagt er kann das
gar nicht ganz einschätzen es kann auch
sein dass anders breivik diese chance
mal wieder nutzt um sozusagen eine
kleine show zu haben und sich zu
präsentieren
seine botschaften zu verbreiten
an andere die ja gleich gesinnt sind und
das haben wir eben ja auch gesehen als
er eben diesen saal betreten hat dass er
wieder den rechten arm gehoben hat darum
wurde auch wild diskutiert im vorhinein
ob man überhaupt anders breivik zeigen
sollte man sieht ihn jetzt nun jetzt
haben aber viele
anbieter des des streams in diesem
prozess war in diesem gerichtssaal haben
sich schon dagegen entschieden dass sie
anders breivik ab 11 uhr 30 zeigen
werden denn ab 11.30 hat anders breivik
drei stunden zeit sich selbst zu äußern
und viele haben sich eben dagegen
entschieden ihnen dann zu zeigen und ihm
die möglichkeit zu bieten diese bühne zu
nutzen sein anwalt selbst hat im
vorhinein vor dem prozess gesagt das
anders breivik sich bestens vorbereitet
habe auf diesen prozess und ganz genau
wisse wie er sich präsentieren wolle und
was er sagen wolle
annika rahlstedt für uns live den
prozess in oslo verfolgt vielen
herzlichen dank für diese informationen
auch für das gespräch mit dem vater
dieses massenmörders wir verfolgen
diesen prozess weiter mit spannung und
auch für sie liebe zuschauern ein
zuschauer auf bild live gibt es
natürlich auch eine dokumentation zu
diesem schrecklichen fall enders
bereitet wir schon ganz tief in die
psyche dieses mannes der 77 kinder
umgebracht hat und bei uns im studio ist
jetzt unser kollege kai feldhaus aus
unserer nachrichtenredaktion
chefreporter größte lichkeit du hast dem
anders beiwerk einmal selbst in die
augen schauen können was hast du da
gesehen in diesen augen nicht viel um
ehrlich zu sein ich war im mai 2012 beim
prozess in oslo bei einem der späteren
prozesstage und habe im gerichtssaal
hinter ihm gesessen weil ich mir einfach
ein bild davon machen wollte wie es
diese atmosphäre wie geht norwegen damit
um wie geht man mit einem solchen
prozess um und breivik
benimmt sich wie ein kind wie ein
überproportioniert es großes sehr
gewalttätiges kind erst grinsend in
diesem gerichtssaal gelaufen aber nicht
mit einem lächeln das irgendwie freude
symbolisiert sondern einfach ausgesehen
dieser mann ist total verunsichert und
musste jetzt seine fassade
aufrechterhalten das heißt er ist
grinsen darum gelaufen man kennt das von
kindern die nicht genau wissen was sie
machen soll dann ein bisschen vor sich
hin getanzt und hat dann da seine rolle
gespielt und ich bin um ehrlich zu sein
total schockiert das sind zehn jahre
vergangen zehn jahre in denen menschen
sich entwickeln sich ja möglicherweise
auch sachen lernen von den leuten im
knast sitzen die den ganzen tag sehr
viel zeit haben dieser mann hat sich
keinen deut geändert das sieht man in
den zwanzig sekunden die wir gerade aus
dem gericht gesehen habe wir sehen jetzt
auch neben sehe gerade die bilder die
sind zehn jahre her dass war der prozess
ist er verurteilt wurde und hinter dir
sehen wir das bild wie er heute aussieht
gewinnen heute in die augen schauen was
beobachtest du wenn du diese beiden
auftritte vergleichs wie verhält er sich
da wenn er einen gerichtssaal betritt
das ist das äußere erscheinungsbild hat
sich tatsächlich geändert aber damals
theilig und käsig und aufgedunsen
heute sieht er sehr athletisch aus hat
jetzt diesen bart und die glatz und so
aber dieses gehabe dieses diese diese
diese posen die einem das sind immer
noch exakt dieselben also eher kommt
rein zeigt eine botschaft rom macht
diesen diesen komischen muss mit der
hand den wahrscheinlich auch nur er
selbst versteht anders breivik ist und
bleibt ein wahnsinnig armes würstchen
aber leider sehr sehr gefährlich ist
jetzt schauen wir mit befremden auf
diese aktuellen bilder aus norwegen also
ein mann der all das getan hat 77
menschen grausam umgebracht hat vor
allem kinder dort auf utoya und er
glaubt offenbar ernsthaft daran dass er
eine chance hat vorzeitig aus der haft
entlassen zu werden und das gericht
verhandelt diesen prozess müssen wir das
überhaupt ertragen ich denke es ist ein
zeichen von stärke des staates norwegen
dass sie jeden straftäter das gleiche
recht einräumen da nämlich aufzutreten
und seinen fall zu verhandeln das habe
ich damals schon gesagt gedacht bei
diesen beiden prozessen im mordprozess
es war ja alles klar es gab hunderte von
zeugen hunderte von opfern oder also
dutzenden von opfern aber auch hunderte
von überlebenden und er hat ja gar nicht
bestritten was er getan hat trotzdem hat
der staat norwegen diesen prozess in
jedem detail ausgerollt und zwar um den
hinterbliebenen eine stimme zu geben
jeder durfte dort vor treten und sagen
er hat mir die schulter geschossen ich
habe mein augenlicht verloren ich habe
ein bein verloren aber hier stehe ich
ich bin stärker als du und das habe ich
als ein ungeheures zeichen von stärke
gefunden die wie dieser staat mit diesem
verbrechen umgegangen ist heute genauso
er hat das recht also geben sie es ihm
damit er bloß nicht die möglichkeit hat
sich als märtyrer zu gerieren und
zusagen knast niemand will mich hören
aber dabei müsste ich doch sie geben
ihnen das recht und dann sperren sie
wieder weg und haben wieder zehn jahre
ruhe besonders eindrucksvoll fand ich
eben gerade der vater von anders breivik
sehr gesprochen hat mit unserer
reporterin annika rage welche rolle hat
er überhaupt
dieses massenmörders gespielt wenn man
diesen alten mann mit gebrochener stimme
sprechen hört dann hat man das gefühl
der spricht ein liebender vater offenbar
ist aber diese beziehung nicht unbedingt
das was sie zu sein scheint welche rolle
später im leben des massenmörders das
täuscht die innsbruck hat im leben des
attentäters ein relativ kleine rolle
gespielt die eltern haben sich getrennt
aber anders breivik ein jahr alt das mag
möglicherweise auch dazu beigetragen
haben dass er wurde was er ist weil
seine mutter das ist im rahmen des
prozesses sehr umfangreich und
detailliert geschildert worden hat ihn
danach nicht sonderlich gut behandelt
er ist mehrfach stand zur stand zur
diskussion dass er in pflegefamilien
gegeben wie etwa die mutter mit ihm
nicht klar kam und so weiter
das soll alles um gottes willen nichts
entschuldigen es gibt ganz viele kinder
die von eltern ich lieb gehabt werden
dann nicht zum massenmörder werden aber
jens breivik hat in seinem leben
zunächst keine rolle gespielt sie haben
sich dann wieder angenähert jens breivik
war dann als diplomat in london und
paris dort hat anders breivik in ab und
an sucht bis sie dann im teenager-alter
dabei bleibe zu 14 15 sich komplett
überworfen haben darstellen beide jetzt
anders da der vater sagte der sohn hat
den kontakt abgebrochen der sohn sagt
der vater hat den kontakt abgebrochen
aber seitdem fliegen die beiden auch
keinerlei kontakt mehr das heißt der
vater ist jetzt wahrscheinlich genauso
opfer wie alle anderen hinterbliebenen
der hat aber zu seinem sohn sehr sehr
wenig kontakt gehabt immer
ferdinand eilfeld hast du deinen besuch
hier im studio auf bild de finden sie
auch eine doku zum fall breivik gestein
in die gestörte psyche des massenmörders
ist eine dokumentation von peter hell
und annika rasch